[Musik]
hallo ich bin's sky dumont und ich
begrüße euch herzlich zu dieser neuen
folge von tatort deutschland die crime
doku von bild heute begeben wir uns tief
in das organisierte verbrechen
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild
die kleinst von berlin
[Applaus]
statt berlin uns aufgeteilt unter den
araber clans prostitution waffenhandel
geldwäsche
schutzgeld menschenhandel jeder hat sein
territorium
gehört eine erpressung vorschrift ohne
geld läuft gar nichts man kann sich
sozusagen ein staat im staate aufbauen
die personen hinter diesem kleinen
mitglied von aussagen werden noch
intensiver zu wort kommen aber zuerst
möchte ich euch etwas kompakten
geschichtsunterricht geben keine angst
das geht schnell und tut nicht weh ihr
müsst nur zuhören alle habt ihr
sicherlich schon von clarens der
kleinkriminalität und clanstrukturen
gehört nennt man das wort so einfach in
den wunsch dann verbindet man es
grundsätzlich mit kriminalität aber
dabei hat es eine lange interessante
geschichte ursprünglich kommt klein von
dem gälischen oder auch irischen
wortklang mit doppeltem n der google
translator gibt schnell das wort kinder
als übersetzung heraus die bedeutung
wird aber auch auf familie abstammung
abkömmlinge erweitert
der begriff taucht demnach schon im
frühmittelalterlichen irland schottland
und england auf wo sich große familien
meist streng religiös und kinderreich
daran machten gegen die obrigkeit zu
agieren und ihre ländereien vor
steuereintreiber und feinden zu schützen
das oberhaupt dieser sippen oder
großfamilien war immer das schief der
letztlich das finale wort zu sprechen
hatte clans hat es vermutlich in jeder
region der welt gegeben und wir sollten
nicht vergessen dass zum beispiel die
familie des ermordeten präsidenten john
f kennedy auch als der kennedy-clan
bezeichnet wohl und schaut man sich den
umfang und einfluss dieser ihre
stämmigen familie an dann trifft die
bezeichnung clan aber sowas von zu
die clans um die es heute gehen wird
sind letztlich auch hinter einer großen
familie der
islamwissenschaftler ralf gab waren und
michael kuhr ein security experte aus
berlin skizzieren die herkunft der
arabischen clans die in diesem podcast
die zentrale rolle einnehmen
die arabische klaren sind es
1976 in berlin
mehrere familien gewesen sie aus dem
bürgerkrieg gekommen sind die sich auch
kannten und sich dann zusammen
geschlossen haben
damit ist der libanesische bürgerkrieg
gemeint der sich von 1975 bis 1990
hinzog und zu der noch heute verfahrenen
situationen in diesem kleinen land am
mittelmeer geführt hat die meisten
großfamilien flohen damals vor dem
konflikt als am ende der 70er jahre
verschiedene radikale kräfte
unterschiedlicher religiöser ausrichtung
versuchten die macht dem nahen osten an
sich zu reißen martin textor ein ex
leiter des sondereinsatzkommandos sek
erinnert sich in wirklichkeit waren es
oftmals leute die aus der türkei kamen
die aber einfach ihre papiere
weggeschmissen haben und so daten die
flüchtlingsfamilien im libanon ohne
identität und die möglichkeit eines
normalen lebens von einem tag zum
anderen keine jobs keine bildung keine
perspektive
die internationale gemeinschaft tat auch
nur eher halbherzig das allernötigste um
diesen menschen zu helfen
westdeutschland jedoch face den familien
aufnahme und bleiberecht aber in den
diplomatischen wirren des kalten krieges
erfordert die einreise der clans aus dem
libanon kreativität als einfachste weg
erwies sich die rote über die ddr wohin
ist verbal durch den balkan oder mit dem
flieger ging in ost berlin angekommen
nutzen sie dann die möglichkeit eines
tages besuches in west-berlin und
tauchten unter nach und nach erreichten
so viele großfamilien erst west berlin
und später auch westdeutschland über den
transit weg
der islamwissenschaftler gerd bahn kommt
selbst aus dem libanon und steht nach
seiner harschen kritik an den arabischen
clans nun wegen konkrete morddrohungen
unter permanentem polizeischutz
er weiß was die familien in den westen
lockte
ganz großzügig das heißt sie haben alle
sofort wohnungen bekommen sozialhilfe
und dann kleidern
die ganze einrichtung gewohnt haben sie
auch mit zahlen bekommen es gab
schulpflicht von kindergeld das war für
sie wirklich ein
security experte chur fügt noch hinzu
sie waren verteilt den wertigen köln
kreuzberg schöneberg und haben sich da
zusammengefunden und eine community
gebildet was man heute bezeichnet als
parallele
in zusammenhang mit dieser thematik
stellten köln natürlich einen gewissen
brennpunkt da beziehungsweise bestimmte
teile von neukölln chef ermittler des
lka dirk jacob hat neukölln als
brennpunkt erwähnt wer es nicht weiß das
ist ein bezirk in berlin der eigentlich
wiederum aus fünf kleineren einzel
bezirken besteht es neben mitte eine der
am dichtesten besiedelten stadtteil der
metropole auf einem quadratkilometer in
neukölln leben 14.000 einwohner im
restlichen berlin sind es im
durchschnitt
4047 prozent der 170 tausend bürger
neuköllns haben einen
migrationshintergrund
sie sind also menschen die zugewandert
sind wichtig für ein gutes zusammenleben
ist integration aber diese in klein
experte ralph ghadban und michael kuhr
dessen mitarbeiter täglich in den klubs
und lokalen berlins für sicherheit
sorgen kaum erreicht die
kleinkriminalität
hat mit der problematik der integration
bzw werden der integration zu tun viele
wollen ja studieren
das durften sie nicht ich habe nur eine
duldung eine aufenthaltsgenehmigung aber
ihr habt noch kein bleiberecht gar nix
also könnte hier auch nix machen
bildung ist das wichtigste integrative
element oder besser sind es bildung und
arbeit aber genau das arbeiten konnten
die nur geduldeten flüchtlingen nicht
sie sollten nach einer übergangszeit
zurückkehren und gar nicht erst feste
strukturen bilden und auch heute besteht
das problem nach wie vor heinz
buschkowsky ehemalige
bezirksbürgermeister zu den nicht
vorhandenen erwerbsmöglichkeiten und
irgendwie mussten sie ja an geld kommen
und was machen sie denn wenn die jungs
sind leben wollen auch ein gewisses
protz gehabe zu ihrer lebensart gehört
michael kuhr bringt es in seiner rauen
berliner art auf den punkt das ist
kriminell gesagt haben wir wollen ja
auch irgendwo teil der gesellschaft
werden dazu braucht man geld und haben
ihre art selber entwickelt sich geld zu
beschaffen und sie haben sehr sehr
schnell gemerkt dass die deutschen angst
haben und dass man mit dieser angst auch
sehr viel geld verdienen kann und wir
stellten fest dass gerade junge männer
dann nicht sehr zimperlich waren in
berlin hat man es etwa somit immer um
die 20 familien zu tun dr stefan görz
dozent im fachbereich bundespolizei der
hochschule des bundes in lübeck er
schrieb 2018 dazu
die zugehörigkeit des einzelnen zum klar
definiert sich ausschließlich über das
kriterium der verwandtschaft daher
sprechen die sicherheitsbehörden von
familie als krimineller
solidargemeinschaft weiter gehen die
behörden von einer hierarchisch
patriarchalisch geprägten struktur aus
die nach dem prinzip der gemeinsamen
abstammung organisiert ist ebenfalls
charakteristisch ist ein nach außen
dokumentiertes macht und gewinnstreben
auch durch die besetzung öffentliche
rolle
stop mal kurz bevor jetzt aber alle
zugewanderten großfamilien berlins über
einen kamm geschoren werden grätscht ex
sek einsatzleiter text oder zwischen
wenn wir von clans sprechen dann meinen
wir den kriminellen teil ein prozentual
kleiner anteil solcher großen familie
genau und das sollten wir immer im
hinterkopf behalten bei allem was wir
über verbrechen dieser clans im laufe
dieser folge noch hören werden
[Musik]
1989 ist der bürgerkrieg im libanon fast
vorbei aber zurückkehren möchte
augenscheinlich niemand der einmal in
deutschland angekommen ist außerdem ist
schon die nächste generation der
großfamilien im teenager-alter und
berlin bremen essen sind schlicht ihr
zuhause und dann kommt der nächste bruch
in der geschichte
[Musik]
der ton auf der straße grauer die
großfamilien rücken noch näher zusammen
was zählt ist jetzt
durchsetzungsvermögen gegen die neuen
eindringlingen eine radikalisierung
setzt ein
sie waren bereit zu schießen aber die
deutschen kriminellen war nicht bereit
zu schießen und das haben sie gemacht
und das haben sie sehr erfolgreich
gemacht dass ich durchgesetzt hör den
us-bürger
ihre gebiete übernommen und
komplett von den deutschen sie haben
dann ruckzuck englisch das umfeld von
von drogengeschäften wollen es war ein
sieg auf ganzer breite und langsam
kristallisierten sich aus dem familien
geflecht erste immer wiederkehrenden
namen heraus wenn es um prostitution
drogengeschäfte waffenschmuggel
geldwäsche räuberische erpressung geht
[Musik]
die wichtigsten namen denke ich mal sind
seine familie oder die abus gastfamilien
die familie rath die familie ali khan
jahre waren wir hier über familie faktor
von prostitution waffenhandel geldwäsche
schutzgeld menschenhandel
erpressung
security experte michael kuhr weiß von
was er spricht als türsteher begann er
seine karriere heute führt er ein
erfolgreiches sicherheitsunternehmen das
sich durch seine enge kooperation mit
der polizei auszeichnet deswegen ist
auch eine tür interessant nachdem
das dazu in vielen clubs und daher sind
türen sehr wichtig das war damals zum
beispiel johann wertingen
club der sehr bekannt sehr groß war und
man hat dann ausländer hingeschickt die
vorne stress gemacht massiv erschweren
dass ein besucher von einem dieser
stress mehr sagt hamann ich habe gehört
dass wir haupt und wir sind hier in
wedding hier sind da doch sehr viele
migranten und das ist doch besser wenn
ihr jemanden von uns mit anna türen und
dann habt ihr problem denn bei einer mit
einer tür aber der denn natürlich seine
ganzen freunde auch freie geholt und hat
dann erklärt die müssen auch taten falls
irgend eine andere gruppe kommt eine
andere gruppierung anerkannt müssen wir
verteidigen deswegen sind auch immer
mehr
familienangehörige dazu gekommen da war
die stimmung nicht so gut und regeln bis
man schlägerei
[Applaus]
dieser ruppiger umgangston ist gang und
gäbe schon bei kleinsten kontrollen
durch sicherheitskräfte tauchen meist
sofort andere clan mitglieder auf was
passiert
[Musik]
das ist bewusste einschüchterungspolitik
dr stefan görz dazu
nach angaben des deutsch chinesischen
islamwissenschaftlers ralf guard bahn
behindern die familienclans die arbeit
der polizei wo es geht bedrohen
polizisten und schüchtern diese ein
wollen die polizei und andere behörden
maßnahmen durchführen stehen schnell
dutzende mitglieder der clans um sie
herum blockieren beschimpfen sie fangen
schlägereien an dadurch entstehen no go
areas also rechtsfreie räume
diesen druck müssen beamte aber auch
private sicherheitsdienste wie der von
michael kuhr täglich aushalten das hat
dazu geführt dass der klub zu gemacht
hat dann kam neuer inhaber der dänen
aufgemacht mit den namen palace nicht ob
die türöffnung und hatte natürlich auch
gespräche mit klaren wie wir sagt haben
die hier waren eine tür und wir wollen
gerne hier wieder mit an der tür
paradeiser bei mir funktioniert das
nicht ich hab ne ganz andere politik als
andere flächen türsteher bereich ich
mache alles komplett zu 100 prozent
das hat geklappt bis heute
diese politik durchsetzen können
wie fühlt sich das eigentlich auf der
anderen seite an dennis witt ist ein
clown insider der gerade noch den
absprung geschafft hat eine kriminelle
karriere fing mit 13 an ich glaube ich
hab schon fast mit jeder großfamilie
straftaten gegangen eigentlich fast nur
raubüberfälle oder einbrüche diebstähle
also eigentlich fast das volle programm
den meisten kontakt von dem araber clans
hatte ich mit der familie sein und ist
heute noch einige freunde von denen aber
mit den meisten habe ich den kontakt
abgebrochen weil ich keinen sinn mehr
gesehen habe unser tagesablauf war so
was machst du treffpunkt café karten
spielen und dann wurde nur über
geschäfte geredet oder wie machen wir
geld wie kommen wir an geld dran also da
gab es nicht mit kombi desktop client
oder kommende gehen mein steam oder so
was gab es nicht also viele von denen
haben auch keine hobbys hat sich alles
nur um geld gedreht hat mich entschieden
auszusteigen weil ich bin trainer des
jahres acht jahre im knast meine familie
hat darunter gelitten ich habe darunter
gelitten und im endeffekt halten die
nicht zu dir sind deine freunde jahre
lang und dann passiert einmal eine
kleine steht ein kleiner fehler und
schon bist du der buhmann nur weil
dennis im knast saß hatte sich soweit
respekt im klaren verdient dass er in
ruhe gelassen wird er berichtet er
ungerührt von seinem leben im kleinen
stadt berlin uns aufgeteilt unter den
araber klangs und
jeder hat sein territorium die leute die
die meiste kohle haben den besitzen auch
macht und ansehen ihrer stadt ohne geld
läuft gar nichts neuköllns
bezirksbürgermeister heinz buschkowsky
hat ebenfalls sehr persönliche
erfahrungen in bezug auf respekt und
ansehen gemacht
immer ein
liebgewordenes opfer
von cell hat man lud mich auch gerne zum
teetrinken nach hause zu kommen ein habe
ich nie gemacht mein eindruck war immer
dass die familien schon wert darauf
legten ein entspanntes verhältnis zum
bürgermeister zu haben im bis hin zur
ausgesprochen und gegen
ansprachen von jungen halbwüchsigen
männern nach dem motto bürgermeister
hast du feinde sagt bescheid wir kämpfen
für dich jede familie hat ihr
territorium in dem sie das sagen hat und
man sieht eigentlich zu sich nicht ins
gehege zu kommen es hört sich nette an
den bürgermeister schützen zu wollen
aber letztendlich sprechen die clans dem
staat hier die autorität ab diesen
schutz zu leisten heinz buschkowsky
sieht auch schuld im sozialen system
deutschlands dass es für clevere leute
mit krimineller energie sehr einfach
macht auf ressourcen zuzugreifen und
diese auszunutzen wenn die deutschen so
dämlich sind das also was ich uns geld
zahlen hat 4 unter und unternehmen wir
das dankbar gerne entgegen aber das ist
es dann auch sie hier haben eine
ausschließliche binnensicht ich das
können sie daran erkennt dass in
einzelfällen leute schon das siebzehnte
mal beim fahren ohne führerschein
erwischt werden kann adressiert sie gar
nicht die familien akzeptieren die
deutsche strafjustiz und auch die
deutsche polizei
als übergeordnete instanz sondern sie
sehen sich schon auf einer ebene und sie
sehen es als einen ständigen kampf wer
der stärkste ist sie haben auch immer
das bestreben im sozialraum deutlich zu
machen dass an ihnen kein weg vorbeigeht
und die machtfrage wird permanent
gestellt gegen alle staatlichen
institutionen weil die deutschen gesetze
interessieren nicht und die deutschen
lebensregeln auch nicht
[Musik]
alles außerhalb des stammes ist
feindesland
islamexperte kartbahn sieht auch schon
eine neue entwicklung eine ausweitung
der kampfzone
die herrschaft hat sich geändert das
heißt früheren war es lokal in ihrem
wohngebiet jetzt mit den neuen techniken
und mit der geldwäsche versuchen sie
neue gebiete zu erobern also wie zuletzt
zum beispiel diese messerstecherei in
charlottenburg am albertplatz zeit dass
sie jetzt überall sind und überall heißt
die illegalen einkünfte in ganz berlin
anzulegen 6 sek einsatzleiter martin
textor weiß dass von dutzenden
wohnungsdurchsuchungen und wenn man
dieses geld dann in berlin entsprechend
anlegt beispielsweise in immobilien das
ist gerade jetzt im moment unheimlich in
dann kann man damit eben reichtum und
einfluss haben man kann sich also dann
aussuchen wer zieht da in meiner häuser
ein mann kann sich sozusagen eine ein
staat im staate aufbauen und genau auf
diesem wege sind diese arabischen
großfamilie wie umfangreich diese
vermögenswerte sind zeigt eine
pressekonferenz nach einem einsatz der
staatsanwaltschaft berlin am 19 07 2018
der 77 grundstücke sind weil 12
durchsuchen vorläufig sichergestellt
worden hintergrund ist der vorwurf der
geldwäsche wir reden von einem
gesamtwert nach der zeit der lage von
993 millionen euro und im zuge dieser
ermittlungen ist dann aufgefallen dass
einer brüder der bis dato eigentlich
immer nur empfänger von
transferleistungen war also hartz 4
kindergeld betreuungsgeld dergleichen
auf einmal eigentumswohnungen erwarten
wir unter suchen jede möglichkeit woher
kann dieses vermögen stammen dass wir
jetzt vorläufig gesichert haben
personenschützer michael kuhr und ex
bezirksbürgermeister heinz buschkowsky
sind sich einig also das geld was man
schwarz schwer erarbeitet hat durch
schutzgeld prostitution oder eben teil
traut wird dann legal angelegt
[Musik]
spielhallen spät dies wohnungs
vermietungen um dort ganz offiziell sich
geld herauszuziehen und dann auch
offiziell leben zusammen und eine
gesellschaftlich zahlt steuern wer jetzt
lapidar mit abschieden kommt täuscht
sich man muss auch nicht vergessen dass
mit der alte regelung viele die deutsche
staatsangehörigkeit besitzen also ich
schätze über die hälfte von denen
mindestens die gehirn total zu und man
kann sie nicht abschieben
[Musik]
der ex klein angehörige eine sharuz
shalicar gibt uns ähnlich wie dennis
witt einblicke in die inneren strukturen
der clans er ist im stadtteil wedding
aufgewachsen und mitglied einer
jugendgang gewesen später haben sich die
männer vom all seinen clan untergemischt
als er mal wieder durch seine alte
straße läuft und die tags an den wänden
betrachtet bleibt er vor einem fenster
stehen
das war mein schlafzimmer jung
dieser silberne tag hsp
das war meine erste graffiti gennaro
baby rossi bin ich sehe war mein bester
kumpel damals und profi heißt sowie
gängen als signal habe ich mich
wie zu zeiten wo ich hier mit dem black
panthers unterwegs war
l sein clan mit mir oder an mir oder
neben mir oder hinter mir hatte habe ich
mich hier wie gott auf erden geführt auf
den straßen berlins teil seien klar das
sind kurdische libanesen kurden aus dem
libanon ein riesen klar viele leute sehr
sehr aggressiv einige von den muss das
als 13-jähriger schon angst und mein
leben haben wenn einer von denen sich
auf die tiger hat und so habe ich mich
halt versuchte anzupassen ich hatte eine
pistole im halfter unter der jacke dann
hatte ich einen springer messer in der
anderen tasche und noch so ein
schlagring in einer anderen tasche also
ich war gerüstet als wenn ich jeden tag
den krieg ziehen
mehrmals habe ich angebote bekommen bei
überfällen mitzumachen bei einbrüchen
mit zu machen wo ich glücklicherweise
nicht mitgemacht habt weil sonst welche
wahrscheinlich für längere zeit ins
gefängnis gekommen ich würde heute würde
ich nicht zu fuß nachts alleine in
gegenden spazieren laufen sag ich mal wo
aber clans oder so was zu sagen haben
wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwie in berlin
geblieben wäre und mit denen strom
gehabt hätte ich hätte keinen anderen
weg gehabt außer aus sondern um dem zu
entkommen
[Musik]
ich bin ausgewandert security
unternehmer chur hat von so etwas schon
oft gehört dass man sich einmal endet
mit clowns geschäftlich dann kommt man
da ganz ganz schwer aus oder gar nicht
sehr schwer zu lösen es gibt auch andere
wege wir haben die möglichkeit hier auch
in berlin in deutschland zu leben wo
zudem ohne kriminell zu sein und viele
viele bauern das aber die sache eben
dieser familien so dieser familien druck
da kann man sich manchmal enthält wenn
man dort groß geworden ist schwer
entziehen wie sagt man freunde kann man
sich aussuchen die familien nicht und
strafe strukturen notieren erlebte
schadecker im all seinen clan jeden tag
es gibt in diesen plans gibt es
natürlich einen inneren kern der festes
wo man kaum ran kommen kann und dann
gibt's neusserin kreis
zugezogen zu geheiratet oder fußsoldaten
sein dass es gibt da verschiedene levels
von mitgliedern sagen wir mal und in
diesen levels nehmen die frauen die
unterste stufe 1 was einer modernen
europäischen sicht auf die
gleichberechtigung völlig widersprechen
was haben wir eingangs festgestellt
kleins sind religiös und kinderreich das
trifft auch hierzu zum beispiel gibt es
das innerhalb der familie heiraten wenn
du gar nie genannt kritik daran brachte
islamwissenschaftler ralf barth waren
morddrohungen ein die unterdrückung der
frau spielt eine entscheidende rolle in
der clan strukturen zu der stärkung der
clan struktur ist wie endo grammy ein
wichtiges element damit man unter sich
bleibt die er mit der cousine zwangsehen
sind die regel bei den clans mit
minderjährigen sind die regel also ab 14
ist man schon so weit bei den menschen
sie müssen heiraten und kinder erzeuge
und das läuft ohne den zwang nicht und
wenn eine frau sich daran nicht hält da
gibt es keine gnade
[Musik]
hi
[Applaus]
mal
auf seinem spaziergang durch den wedding
und die vergangenheit wird schade schade
irgendwann nachdenklich fast machst 25
jährige der keinen abschluss hat keine
ausbildung hat ein studium hat und die
leute um dich herum die geld machen
macht uns auf jede gewalt was machst du
mein leben auf der straße damals und
während meiner jugend in berlin wedding
und überhaupt hat einerseits narben am
körper hinterlassen ob hier hier
hat aber auch tief sitzende
traumatischen haben im kopf hinterlassen
während er das erzählt zeigte seine
heftigen narben auf dem kopf und am
oberkörper
sie sehen so aus als hätte die
verletzung ihn töten können celik hatte
vermutlich einfach glück die aggression
der clans nach innen und vor allem nach
außen ist programm und teil der brutalen
strategie die macht zu erhalten
es muss man festhalten
[ __ ]
aller kinder die opfer roddick ist schon
was dran sein
islamwissenschaftler gerd bahn kennt die
taktik hinter dieser gruppendynamik
klein aussteiger denn es wird hat sie
selbst angewandt wenn sie als gruppe
auftreten da können sie viel erreichen
und das haben sie entwickelt und
verfeinert wenn es jetzt ärger gab es
damals oder so mit irgendwelchen anderen
mitgliedern oder mit irgendwelchen alle
anderen nationalitäten ja dann ist man
dann mit 30 mann aufgetaucht ja und wenn
das nicht geholfen hat wenn es man halt
zu den typen hause gegangen und hatten
dank verdroschen also die leute gehen
bischofskanzlei also die shrek nicht
zurück der personenschützer kur erlebte
es jeden tag vor den clubs der
hauptstadt aus einer kleinen verwarnung
durch den kleinen chef wird schnell mehr
ohne dass es gründe dafür braucht die
hand sitzt ziemlich locker als erstes
gibt
und wird er sagte war so auf macht das
so wie wir das wollen wenn nicht dann
erheblich empfindlicher und die haben
wir jetzt auch eine neue taktik dass er
jemand mit messer hier oktober den
oberschenkel stechen in der offenen
klasse anschlag ahnung was getroffen
wird man vermutet
[Musik]
und man konnte sich für mord sondern für
den gefährlicher körperverletzung
so oder so führt dieser weg dann
irgendwann auf eine anklagebank aber
auch dort haben die kleins sehr gut
vorgesorgt
drohpotenzial und das geld reichen weit
wenn es sein muss der ehemalige
bezirksbürgermeister von neukölln kennt
das sehr wohl und das eben großfamilien
die keinerlei skrupel haben für die
gewaltanwendung soll normal ist wie
zähneputzen die natürlich immer die
möglichkeit haben zu beeinflussen
polizeibeamte zu beeinflussen richter zu
beeinflussen staatsanwälte zu
beeinflussen das ist so
ein amtsgericht in berlin ein verfahren
gegen den abou chaker klären ein
reporter versucht an informationen zu
kommen und spricht arafat abou chaker
und einen zeugen an haben sie den zeugen
eingeschüchtert dass er alles vergessen
hat guten morgen da sich sie doch mal
fragen warum sie sich an nichts mehr
erinnern können
haben sie angst vor der familie auto
show kann
nichts dazu sagen bitte haben sie
verständnis dafür dass wir da und dass
ich dann natürlich auch keine
erklärungen abgeben kann was ist denn
los wie kann es immer
[Musik]
so detailliert waren die wohl nicht
warten sie es ab was jetzt passiert
gedächtnisverlust gibt es also nicht nur
in der politik bei schwarzen kassen und
korruptionsskandalen auch in kleinen
prozessen schlägt die am see oder eben
ein sehr guter anwalt zu
security-experte chur also diese class
haben natürlich auch sehr viel geld und
können sich auch die teuersten anwälte
der stadt leisten und natürlich eine
große rolle weil die sind gut
aufgestellt und können die besten hotels
normale zeugen bekannt bei denen
anmelden die kriegen dann mitunter
hausbesuche wo klargemacht wird du
siehst du dir aus habe durch den
glücklichen
hier muss ich mal anhand der sehr
bekannten abou chaker familie erklären
wieso ein kran aufgebaut ist der kern
geht zurück auf seiten asma busacca die
im palästinensischen flüchtlingslager
war will in der nähe der stadt baalbek
im libanon geboren wurden mitte der 70er
jahre flohen sie jedenfalls mit den
ersten vier kindern vor dem
libanesischen bürgerkrieg nach
deutschland es folgten fünf weitere in
west berlin geborene kinder insgesamt
sechs söhne nasser ali arafat rommel
mohammed und jasser man beachte die
namen alles namen von antisemiten nazis
oder israel und juden hassen und drei
töchter der familie folgten weitere
brüder und cousins mit ihren familien
nach deutschland kurz oben die brüder
haben fast alle einen kriminellen
hintergrund
auffälligstes familienmitglied aber ist
arafat der 1976 in berlin geborene
arafat abou chaker gilt dass eine
führungsfigur des clans im jahr 2008
geriet erstmals in den blickpunkt der
öffentlichkeit als er das management des
rappers bushido übernahm und den kennt
eigentlich jeder der mal ein radio
eingeschaltet hat
später trennten sich die beiden wieder
im januar 2009 10 wurde arafat busacca
vom amtsgericht tiergarten
erstinstanzlich wegen körperverletzung
und bedrohung zu einer zehnmonatigen
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt deren vollzug
zur bewährung ausgesetzt wurde das
landgericht berlin wandelte das urteil
später in einem berufungsprozess in eine
geldstrafe von 90 tagessätzen zu je 165
euro um ein schnäppchen die behauptung
er sei clan chef wies er von sich wieso
kommen die meisten familienmitglieder
vor gericht immer so glimpflich davon ex
bezirksbürgermeister heinz buschkowsky
lachte nur
die
verstorbene richterin heisig hat mir mal
berichtet dass ein alibi etwa 10.000
euro kostet wenn es um den vorwurf von
raubtaten oder ähnlichem ging es kann
dann natürlich auch vor dass schweiger
alibi gelder kassiert worden und dann
die zusage nicht eingehalten wurde das
führte dann zu konflikten zwischen den
familien und da gab's deine hin und
wieder richtig stress
denn jetzt eine familie beispielsweise
200 schließfächer frisch oder eine
goldmünze cloud oder so dann gibt es
auch viel eifersucht untereinander und
sagt guck mal der krone gemacht hat
alles nur mit geld zu tun und eifersucht
mit leid denn es wird meint damit den
diebstahl einer 100 kilogramm schweren
goldmünze aus dem bode museum in berlin
im jahr 2017 im wert von ca
3,75 millionen euro und er berichtet von
eigenen überfällen
stand von einer straftat berichten nicht
mit jemand aus einer arabischen
großfamilie begangen habe das war ein
überfall auf ein gold kurier das war
eine blitzaktion gewesen hammer material
haben wir immer im auto haben dann die
piloten station gemacht dann unser auto
haben ein parkhaus gewartet bis die
leute raus kam haben die dann verfolgt
in berlin kann wieder zugeschlagen genau
müller straße ecke seestraße vor allen
leuten ausgestiegen
aus unserem auto mit dem hammer die
scheiben eigentlich schlangen die gold
kupfer entrissen den leuten ins auto
gestiegen und danach abgeholt und von
allen seiten krank polizei und zivis und
haben uns dann rost geholt der eine ist
abgehauen dahin aus dem arabischen groß
klein und ist und ein anderer sohn
verurteilt ich denke dass viele von den
familienmitgliedern nie satt werden also
es gibt es immer welche die sagen okay
jetzt rechts und so aber viele von denen
auch hier haben das im blut die kündigt
ohne ohne scheiße baum
bei geplanten überfällen wird das so
vorbereitet dass man wochen wenn nicht
monate vorher dem nahen observiert
wartet jemand vor dem land sitzen
outdoor trinkt seinen kaffee beobachtet
alles von morgens bis 18 19 uhr guckt wo
die leute hingehen wo die leute wohnen
an der lahn aufgemacht wird fotografiert
macht videos grund sich die alarmanlage
falls doch eingebrochen wird oder ob mit
einem autorennen gefahren wird das wird
so perfekten alles organisiert sodass
ein gestank schiefgehen kann deswegen
werden sie sich auch fast nie erwischt
vielleicht von 100 fällen oder so
vielleicht zwei dreimal ja und dann
sitzen so ein idiot wie ich oder wie in
welchen anderen leute sitzen für diese
leute dann and hast ja und das sind
seine leute die denken nur an sich so
klingt es wenn man am potsdamer platz
seine internationale pokerrunde oder das
berühmteste kaufhaus ausraubt wir
erinnern uns dass die apothekerfamilie
da
250.000 euro raus trug für das kadewe
war ein andere klären die remos
verantwortlich
großen kriminalfällen ist die familie
abou chaker es kann auch mal um die
familie homogen weil die auch
regelmäßige gäste in den
justizvollzugsanstalten sind es aus
meiner sicht der pokerwelt war für mich
völlig unlogisch dort eine aktion
überhaupt zu starten ab betreten des
hotels oder waren kameras er sich jeder
hat ja hier geplant
aber man nimmt den knast in kauf oder
begrüßt sogar das prestige was man
dadurch im klaren erlangt manchmal
laufen die geschäfte auch im knast
einfach weiter aussteiger dennis witt
und i'll sharuz shalicar erinnern sich
die meisten leute in der jva tegel im
handel betreiben sind araber clans l
sein rennrad die anderen haben gar
nichts zu sagen hier so deutsche die
wären hier und da drückt ihn erniedrigt
hier das sind meistens auch die leute
oder russen die das zeug kaufen aber die
groß zicker sind meistens die addax hier
gibt es manche leute die zu mir gesagt
haben denn es ist verdienen hier 15.000
euro im monat ich werde im nächsten
monat entlassen ich will gar nicht nach
hause gehen was kann ich machen dass ich
noch länger hier drin der bleibe also
die haben ja so gut geld verdient dass
sie gar nicht mehr raus gehen wollten
das gehört eigentlich auch zu christie's
dazu dass man ins gefängnis geht und
wieder raus kommt und dann ist man auch
eine größere nummer haftaufenthalt ist
nicht nur deswegen für die so wichtig
weil das image steigt sondern dass auch
deswegen wichtig weil man beweisen kann
dass die familien auch einfluss haben
dass es ihnen im knast nicht schlecht
geht und einen wichtigen punkt bringt
eine sharuz shalicar noch an über den
man intensiver nachdenken sollte ein
problem ist natürlich auch wo dieses
geld teilweise hinfließt ob herz im
libanon ob an terrororganisationen da
wird aus dieser mikro berlin spielen
eine internationale geschichte und eine
der stärksten ist die stärkste besetzung
der weltfussballer christopher setzen
libanon das sind schiitische libanesen
und die programme geld aus der ganzen
welt ohne jetzt groß drauf eingehen zu
wollen aber ich denke dass das klar wo
die teilweise ihr geld herbert
diess dollar ist eine islamistische para
militärische organisation die faktisch
den größten teil des libanon
kontrolliert und in einem permanenten
kriegszustand mit israel steht die hamas
in gaza unterstützt und für
raketenangriffe und selbstmordattentate
verantwortlich ist 6 sek einsatzleiter
textor weiß der knast ist was für die
meist jungen täter auf höherer ebene
wird das unter dem clan führen geklärt
er und chef-ermittler dirk jacob wissen
wie das läuft die jeweiligen
familienoberhäupter tauschen sich aus
setzten sich zusammen muss man sich
nicht als fairen prozess vorstellen
sondern es geht darum wer ist der
stärkere part gewalt und wer muss
sozusagen den schwanz einziehen und
gehen weil er da nicht mitkommt mit
dieser gewalt unter stellte sich dann
relativ schnell heraus dass er es
einigungsprozess kulturell bedingte
einigungsprozess gibt die wir als
parallel schlichtung bezeichnen und weil
sich das ebenso intern abspielt und
nicht vor den augen der polizei gibt es
auch so wenig ermittlungs anhaltend dazu
in den parallelen justizsystem dass wir
hier leider enthalten feststellen müssen
gibt es sehr unterschiedliche
mechanismen wir haben
familienoberhäupter respektspersonen
zur streitschlichtung herangerufen
werden die selber nicht unbedingt streit
beteiligte sind diese parallele
schlichtung nennt man friedensrichter
eine übergeordnete respektsperson der
clans hört sich dann die vorgetragene
problematik an legt ab und entscheidet
meist läuft das dann über geld wobei
sich der friedensrichter eine gewisse
marge als honorar einbehalten darf
gerade in stammes geprägten regionen des
nahen ostens im libanon und syrien ist
das seit jahrhunderten gang und gäbe
einfach mannes anderer institutionen in
deutschland gibt es aber eine
unabhängige justiz interessiert die
clans aber nicht manchmal hat das wirken
der clans etwas von gangster komödie
manchmal herrscht stammes folklore aber
die kleinsten extrem gewaltbereit und
der ex bürgermeister von neukölln heinz
buschkowsky versteht da schon lange
keinen spaß mehr in einem fall hat ja
auch ein sek beamter das mit dem leben
bezahlt dieser tödliche schuss bei der
festnahme aus der wohnung war will
polizistin eine tragische verkettung
martin textor vom sek berichtet ich war
leiter unter anderem des
spezialeinsatzkommandos und das
spezialeinsatzkommando wurde sehr oft
eingesetzt wenn die zielperson nieder zu
beobachten waren oder die festgenommen
werden mussten aus einem der arabischen
großen plans kam in dem moment wo die
reinging und laut riefen polizei hatte
der täter der am ende des flurs in dem
zimmer sah sofort seine pistole gezogen
hat eigentlich
eigentlich nur in die richtung
geschossen und traf ihn unter seinem
linken auge die bz berichtete im april
2003 dazu
gestern abend um 1855 wurde ihm der
haftbefehl wegen totschlags verkündet
gestern morgen wurden die vier männer
aus der todesdrohung zur mordkommission
gebracht zur vernehmung es sind yasin
a33 und a22 oma a27 und hussain a59
alles angehörige derselben
libanesischen großfamilie unmittelbar
nach den schüssen auf die beiden
elitepolizisten in der
erdgeschosswohnung in der kienitzer
straße wurden die vier männer
überwältigt während die notärzte sich um
die niedergeschossenen kümmerten klebten
sek-beamte den libanesen sofort die
hände mit klebeband ab zum sichern von
schmauchspuren die müssen an den händen
des todesschützen haften es waren die
hände von yasin a es war in uns allen so
etwas drin wie uns passiert nichts wir
sind so gut ausgebildet wir machen keine
fehler es passiert uns nichts eigentlich
wollen wir unbesiegbar der täter war
nicht auffällig er war nicht hämisch vor
gericht dass er damals verurteilt wurde
dass er relativ schnell verurteilt wurde
bis m sek mit wohlwollen begleitet
wurden die 15 jahre haftstrafe saß ja
china bis zum letzten tag
nach seiner entlassung sollte er in den
libanon abgeschoben werden nach einem
gerichtlichen streit über die
rechtmäßigkeit verließ der familienvater
im september 2009 10 tatsächlich
deutschland freiwillig doch nur für
kurze zeit die vier in haft gezeugten
kinder jungen und mädchen mit deutscher
staatsangehörigkeit waren sein ticket
zurück nach deutschland heinz
buschkowsky traut dem familienfrieden
nicht ich glaube dass bestimmte dinge
bei uns für normalbürger unverständlich
so wie ein
polizistenmörder nach 15 jahren also
immer noch als junger mann wieder durch
die straßen laufen kann als ob überhaupt
nichts geschehen wäre und er nunmehr ein
treuer bürger ist das versteht kein
mensch und ich glaube auch nicht dass in
einem anderen staat auf dieser erde das
möglich wäre das ein polizistenmörder
quasi als rehabilitiert zu betrachten
ist
gemordet wird auch untereinander im
herbst 2008 10 wurde so in
berlin-neukölln der 36 jährige
intensivtäter nidal r durch mitglieder
des clan milieu schossen einfach auf dem
tempelhofer feld einem großen ausflugs
areal mitten in berlin
[Musik]
trotz der guten
luft wir machen noch nicht
in berlin ist auf offener straße einen
mann erschossen worden wieder er
deutscher staatsbürger palästinensischer
herkunft war ein bekannter intensivtäter
mit dutzenden vorstrafen person an
arabischen großfamilie soll sich im
milieu viele feinde gemacht haben
agierte für verschiedene clans
wenig später wird die dahlie beigesetzt
und was dann passiert ist erstaunlich
[Musik]
mindestens 2000 trauergäste sind
gekommen um abschied zu nehmen von nidal
r
zuletzt soll sich der getötete mit
arafat abou chaker dem ex partner von
bushido verbündet haben die mutmaßlichen
mörder sind auf der flucht
wer genau das klein mitglied getötet hat
weiß man noch nicht vielleicht wird man
es nie erfahren wie sharuz shalicar
michael kuhr und denn es wird
feststellen vielleicht war es auch ganz
andere konkurrenz im untergrund sehr
viele arabische familien unterwegs aber
nicht nur das trifft doch rockerbanden
die spiele natürlich ohne erhebliche
oder hier denn der lehrer nachtleben
darf man nicht unterschätzen
das verhältnis zwischen rockern und
rabatt plans ist eingeschritten ist okay
das ist keine richtige freundschaft das
ist eher so eine politische freundschaft
aber alles alles enthält und macht und
einfluss geht des hengstes alles nur
politisch man nach denjenigen ins
gesicht gehabt oder bruder christian
berg wissen da aber innerlich glaube ich
mag man sich nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
diese aufnahme stammt von einem bushido
konzert bushidos damaliger manager
arafat abou chaker verpasste einem gast
eine dicke ohrfeige nicht die feine art
mit fans umzugehen arafat spielte sich
als könig der gangster hip-hop-szene der
araber auf ex clan mitglied und graffiti
sprayer charly kahr weiß wie es kam vor
20 jahren gab es eine zeit wo viele die
aus dem graffiti business oder
kriminellen business ein bisschen älter
wurden und überlegt haben wie mache ich
jetzt geld in einen rap business
eingestiegen sind das sind dann die
jungs gewesen die so teilweise kriminell
waren broschüre war keiner der und wie
groß oder zähne und was zu sagen hatte
die dann ein bisschen talent hatten und
was die dann auf dem legalen weg in die
richtige richtung bringen los wenn
dadurch einmal ein lässt dass diese
clans und deshalb bilder gemacht dann
bist du den ausgeliefert du bist deren
grund gebiss deren fußabtreter bushido
ist ein hund gewesen für die er hat sie
mit bereichert um schutz zu bekommen
schutz vor anderen
[Musik]
bushido geboren am 28 september
1978 in bonn als anis mohamed youssef
ferchichi auch bekannt unter dem
pseudonym sonny black ist ein deutscher
rapper und songwriter dessen stil sich
an den us amerikanischen gangsta rap
anlehnt er arbeitet auch als produzent
und ist inhaber eines plattenlabels
bushido hat im gleichen beitrag auch
inhalts punkte wie beleidigung
steuerhinterziehung versicherungsbetrug
und körperverletzung erscheint einige
feinde gehabt zu haben und wandte sich
so an arafat abou chaker mit der bitte
um schutz der wurde schnell bester
freund manager und vertraglicher vormund
und später noch ein weiterer allerdings
mächtiger feind auf bushidos liste
zwischen arafat und bushido herrscht
anscheinend ein streit und nun hat sich
bushido entschieden diesen weg alleine
weiter zu gehen ohne den absacker klar
mehrere jahre war der apotheker clan an
der seite von bushido eine vollmacht
wurde unterschrieben doch nun gehen sie
offiziell getrennte wege und es ging wie
immer nicht um kunst sondern um kohle
der pressesprecher der berliner polizei
thilo kablitz meint dazu in der
musikszene geht es erfahrungsgemäß bei
streitigkeiten häufig um
millionenbeträge wir sind uns der gefahr
bewusst dass der streit zwischen bushido
und seinem ehemaligen management
eskalieren könnte wenn du erst von
diesen araber clans zu tun hast und die
an dir geld verdienen mit deiner
einwilligung was dann ja nicht mehr
illegal ist dann findest du da kaum ein
weg raus heute steht bushido unter
permanentem polizeischutz
die von ihm in seinen songs oft mit viel
hass bedachte polizei sorgt heute für
die sicherheit des mehrfachen
familienvater
so kann's gehen tja aber dem thema musik
und clans nehmen wir uns noch intensiver
in der nächsten folge dieses podcasts an
ein weiteres thema zur geldbeschaffung
ist menschenhandel für die araber in den
clans zeichnete sich mit den
flüchtlingen des syrien konflikts ein
gewaltiges potenzial für kriminelle
machenschaften ab in den landes
auffanglagern wurde sprach festes
personal gesucht das wach aufgaben und
versorgung übernahm das taten diese dann
auch aber für sich dabei vergaßen sie
völlig dass ihre eltern und großeltern
der einst auch flüchtlinge war so froh
mitglied einer großfamilie erinnert sich
an die goldgräberstimmung damals in der
zeit von 2014 also wo sie angefangen
haben die haben so viele leute
kennengelernt rekrutieren zu sich geholt
also die können sich erstmal zehn jahre
lang ruhe setzen warnt hatten ihre 50 60
flüchtlinge die sie mitgenommen haben
ist haben konstant eingeladen macht man
das hast du ein bisschen koks bogen
irgendwas aber da fragt man sich hier im
park die verzweiflung war wirklich sehr
sehr hoch dessen was auch für die
arabischen plans ist zu einfach dass
aufzunehmen manipulation war nicht
schwer die waren nur man hat es
ausgenutzt und anrufern viele frauen
sind wir angekommen lage so auch ohne
den männer- und dann hat uns halt
ausgenutzt die haben die hat zur
position benutzt und eine frau die herr
kuba syrien die niemanden kennt da keine
andere wahl für diese taten was die
flüchtlinge gemacht haben sie wurde nie
mit geld bezahlt und unterkünften ich
bin da schlafen wie krieg zu essen die
kriegt ist wenn was ist wenn ihr hilfe
braucht die helfen euch war die
arabische großfamilie hatten auch hier
drinnen im lage so auch kontakte gab es
in einer zum beispiel ein aufenthalt
braucht oder angenehm irgendwas haben
die dritte gesprochen und an ihrer
stelle bekommen rahmens ersten fünf
sechs monate bekommen sie haben zwei
wochen bekommen durch die kontakte man
sagt ja mal eine hand wäscht die andere
hand ihre geschäfte gemacht mit den
zahlen scheinen mit dem örtlichen
scheinen mit den visa mit dem stempel so
handelt ihr geld gemacht hat mich unter
15.000 euro pro mann machte drin tun und
machen was man will das war einfach eine
geldquelle drinnen goldgrube sagt man so
schön was für eine böse ironie
nachkommen von flüchtlingen beuten
andere flüchtlinge aus es ist einfach
nur eine weitere einnahmequelle
ich denke die polizei ist machtlos gegen
diese clans wir sind hoffnungslos
verloren wir können nur noch eine
gewisse schadensbegrenzung betreiben der
zirkus abgefallen man kann bestimmte
entscheidungen auf polizeilicher seite
in teilen nur durch wirklich eine
kaputtgespart polizei erklären und wer
glaubt wir müssen nur 1000 polizisten in
berlin mehr einstellen und 100 funkwagen
kauf und damit ist dieses problem vom
tisch das ist ein narr gericht politik
muss ihnen den weg frei räumen um
wirklich härte vorgehen zu können denn
es sein muss insoweit glaube ich dass an
dieser stelle das gilt nicht für alle
kriminalitätsbereiche aber für diesen
bereich glaube ich eine
null-toleranz-strategie nur die einzige
antwort des rechtsstaats hier auch sein
kann nach einschätzung des
sicherheitsberaters michael kuhr ist es
in berlin vielleicht schon zu spät noch
lassen sich die neun flüchtlinge von den
clans ausbeuten aber vielleicht schaffen
diese es auch eigene mächtige strukturen
zu entwerfen und so in den kampf um die
macht auf der straße einzutreten wir
dürfen nicht vergessen was er jetzt noch
auf uns zu kommt mit den ganzen
frischling denn die merken die clans von
damals aus dem bürgerkrieg die haben
gute zehn jahre gebraucht um zu jagen
die können ja machen was sie wollen wir
können nicht abgeschoben werden sie
kommen aus zu tricks gebiet ein pass
weggeworfen damit sind sie für immer
hier willkommen wenn sie diese brauchen
sie keine zehn jahre um hier
platzhirsche auch noch zu wehren wir
werden hier versinken einer kriminalität
weil es einfach zu lange dauert bis der
regierung hierüber begreift was los ist
sie leben in ihrer traumwelt und
das läuft alles gut für die kommen ja es
läuft gut für die kriminellen aber wir
sollten nicht aus den augen verlieren
dass es sich noch immer um eine
minderheit handelt und dass die
allermeisten menschen die nach
deutschland kommen einfach ein ruhiges
friedliches leben mit beruf und familie
führen wollen und dies auch tun und so
machtlos ist der staat nicht auch wenn
er lange gepennt hat um das mal so
schnippisch zu sagen
zitat dr stefan görz
die politischen entscheidungsträger
deutschlands haben das problem
kriminellen familienclans erst relativ
spät erkannt und die behörden waren
lange zeit überfordert dass der
deutschen polizei an personal und
möglichkeiten fehlt um kleinkriminalität
als phänomenen bereich der organisierten
kriminalität zu bekämpfen
dabei helfen könnte eine
gesetzesänderung aus dem jahr 2017
seither müssen die behörden nicht mehr
nachweisen dass die familienclans ihr
vermögen illegal erworben haben sondern
müssen diese belegen auf legalem wege an
das geld gelangt zu sein ein guter
anfang denn beim geld tut es weh und da
hört bekanntlich auch die freundschaft
auf über falsche freundschaften und den
kampf gegen die clans in ganz
deutschland geht es in der nächsten
folge
bleibt dran bis dann
tatort deutschland die crime doku von
bild produziert von den wild world
studios
projektleitung lutz neumann und simone
terbrack produktion fabian schaeffler
und felix steht bleiben bildredaktion
christine wahl frank schneider und
stefan netzeband sprecher skyteam